We as Muslim women now . . . When I was a
Muslim woman, we were brought up to believe
in our own submission -- submission to the
will of God, submission to the will of your
parents, submission to the will of your husband.
And submission to the will of the husband
is absolute except when he asks you to forsake
Allah.
Now if we have been indoctrinated to believe
that, then that's how we act.
That's how we behave.
But not all of us . . . and that's I think
what's so fascinating about the human mind
-- is that you cannot enslave the human entirely.
Many of us have been exposed to other ideas.
We have our own personalities, seek freedom.
We can't, I think, wake up to the programming
and de-program ourselves.
And if we become aware of the fact that what
we are programming our kids from generation
to generation is repressive.
We can decide not to do that and to take on
alternative ideas.
We can be, for instance . . . We can wake
up to the fact that the God that says in Chapter
4 verse 34 . . . tells the husband "you have
the right to beat your woman", is the same
God that after we are beaten and bruised,
that we pray to for comfort.
Just waking up to that dissonance alone will,
I think, create a platform for change.
It will create the grounds for change.